this is back - do you know yourself or  do you aspire to be something you might  actually not be this is the toughest  question of it all my man I mean if you  want to be respected and really known  show the [ __ ] up you know I don't know  how much into my content you are but I  always say nobody you've ever met got  there without the hard work just real  you know do you know how insane dailyvee  and the snapchat stories has been to  everybody they didn't realize how hard I  was going at it you can't believe how  many you can't believe how many people's  you know many [ __ ] people used to say  the word luck that that word luck has  gone right back like nobody has the  audacity say that's my face now and I  love it